it's Revolution time again in the
entertainment business wrers make your
favorite show Big Data is bringing big
change and faster than ever before AI
has the potential to disrupt every
corner of the entertainment industry a
new wave of artificial intelligence is
beginning to transform the way entire
Industries operate we can build an
algorithm that listens to all the music
in the world determine what we listen to
and watch the AI predicts much money
this F make and generate new forms of
art generative AI moves from being
something that I think is quite
beautiful to occasionally a little bit
intimidating so who are the winners AI
driven names were two of the top stocks
in the S&P 500 and losers generative AI
is an existential threat to the TV and
film industry this is a real earthquake
not just for the entertainment industry
but for our lives in the 21st
century
losing home I tell you baby I'm going
under I can't help
[Music]
you
God in this studio an artist Alfie is
playing a new song to the boss of his
record label anit anit could you hit
space bar just so I can see my levels
please it's the kind of scene that's
been typical of the music business for
decades we're good to go I
[Music]
think but it was not anit who discovered
Alfie it was
[Music]
AI Alfie castley was one of the artists
that we found through our algorithm
ankit's label is based in Sweden and
uses AI to find new artists across the
world AI hit the right note when it
identified that london-based Alfie had a
big fan base thousands of miles away on
another
continent he's an artist from the UK his
five biggest cities in terms of where
his fans come from are all in Southeast
Asia Alfie's biggest hit teenage Mona
Lisa had about 700,000 streams in his
home country but 7 million in Indonesia
and over 16 million in the Philippines
in its first year it's been viral here
in the Philippines for good Lord knows
how long technology helps you kind of
like find these let's say
counterintuitive patterns I think this
is the one that that both Carl and Savin
and Ramy and kits company is using AI to
get better at spotting opportunities and
Trends in the digital era
AI can analyze metadata from social
media and the behavior of viewers and
listeners faster than other
Technologies you look across Spotify
YouTube SoundCloud any platform that has
data you're looking for signs of someone
raising their hand and saying I think
this is a good song it could be an
addition to a playlist a comment on Tik
Tok the footprints in the
sand the biggest use that we've had for
AI has been how do we take this just
fire hose of content and distill it down
to something that's manageable um on a
human
level yeah I think let's call it if
that's right
guys back in the day the whims of
artists and music Executives dictated
what songs the public would hear digital
technology boosted by AI has now turned
that model on its head you're turning
hundreds of thousands sometimes millions
of people into talent scouts you're
democratizing the selection process to
the
fans you like oh I God that was amazing
oh thank
God AI is the latest chapter in the
story of how big data has completely
transformed the music business over the
past
decade the arrival of streaming services
changed everything from how profits are
made to how songs are
structured musicians now get paid per
play and so there's a particular
incentive to make sure that songs sound
good right at the beginning so that
people don't skip them big data mining
also completely disrupted the world of
video Netflix which launched its
streaming service in 2007 led the way in
using data to choose what content to
make and who to serve it up
to on Netflix everything you do on the
platform is a data
point whether it is overing my mouse on
a tumbnail or opening the browser or for
rewinding and those data points are
being used to train the
algorithm and so with this data they
know what people like they therefore
know what to commission the availability
of big data sets has made it much easier
for creators of all kinds to determine
what kind of content is going to be
popular but AI has really turbocharged
that
effort and that's what one new company
is hoping its use of AI will do to the
film
industry cytic is based in La the
traditional home of Film
Production but it offers a very modern
approach to doing
business using AI to inform decisions
about many aspects of movie
making the ultimate goal is an accurate
prediction of how well a film will do
enabling producers and Studios to tailor
their budgets to expected returns and
reduce the risk of losing
money we identify 19 variables that
really Dy FM performance and move the
needle within 20 seconds thei is able to
provide you with a very detailed risk
rated forecast for box office home video
and TV numbers the beauty of it is you
can go back change any input and within
seconds you have a new forecast let's
start with some key decisions choosing
the cast and crew the AI draws on a
database of nearly 600,000 people and
offers different predictions depending
on who is
selected let's swap our Tom Cruz with
Matt Damon also very strong well
recognized actor that did an action
franchise as well that was very popular
internationally we can rerun this
forecast leaving everything else
constant we can now assess every Talent
out there actor writer director producer
we created algorithms that figure out
the real economic value of this
particular talent in relation to the
particular content project that you have
in
mind the AI also takes other factors
into into account including a film's age
rating genre and
budget and thanks to the fast pace of
technological change there's now another
variable in the mix one that tobas
thinks could be the single most
important of all the script what that
means is breaking down a script in
certain patterns in certain archetypes
characters and really figuring out how
these stories could connect to humans
cytic says its predictions are 85 %
accurate but stresses there are always
outliers our tool can really help you
get a much better understanding of how
your film will perform in the future
this analytic is not built to predict
outliers so it's time to put its powers
to the
test before the release of Barbie we
asked the multi-million dollar
question how much would it make at the
box
office Mar Robbie has been very strong
20 18 19 20 then maybe over the last
couple of months she really had a bit of
a rougher patch in the questional with
Barbie will she bring in the
crowds we're now talking 700 million for
this film in theaters home video TV over
years I got in my pocket Barbie has
joined the 1 billion Club just 17 days
after the film was released two months
after the release of Barbie we caught up
with tobas again and asked about
Barbie's phenomenal success and why the
AI did not predict the full extent of
this our tool actually did exactly what
it was supposed to do it helped to show
that Barbie will be successful film and
would be a positive green light this is
not a crystal ball we did not foresee
that it will become a cultural
phenomenon Barbie is a once in a decade
outlier it's a reminder that AI and big
data do not yet have all the answers I
think there's been a bit of a turn back
towards thinking that actually human
judgment has its place competition can
be stiff for companies in the
entertainment business especially for
streaming services which have
proliferated in recent years subscriber
numbers are Plateau at the same time
companies are finding that they're
having to keep spending billions upon
billions on new content to keep people
subscribed enter stage left generative a
I a new plot twist for the industry and
a new world of possibilities for
creating
[Music]
content generative AI allows people to
actually create
things it got onto the radar of most
Ordinary People in about 2022 when apps
like chat GPT and mid Journey came along
allowing Ordinary People to register for
free and experience some of the
seemingly magic powers of generative AI
generative AI works by training deep
neural networks on large data sets of
for example images and text the system
learns to identify patterns and when
prompted it can generate new content
this new form of AI is enabling some
artists to create new forms of art
people like beatboxer Harry ye also
known as reaps
100 beatboxes use their own voices to
make percussive sounds
through my music and through uh my art
form I've spent a lot of my life trying
to sound like a machine using a data set
of Harry's vocalizations an AI system
has generated these percussive noises a
voice that Harry calls his second
[Music]
self when these synthetic voices were
generated I realized that now a machine
was trying to sound like me the aim was
to produce an interaction almost like a
vocal chess match with some of this
synthetic voice this phrase where I
would
normally is
gone and it's added extra ghost notes or
new
phrases my sort of Sonic lexicon started
to grow what comes out the other side
are streams and streams and streams of
this organic second self something that
is me but not
me the idea of automating has been a key
part in music culture the newness of it
is that identity can be
automated Harry has also used AI for a
groundbreaking collaboration with the
leipsig ballet in
Germany the dancers's movements were
recorded and this was used to create a
data set AI then suggested new movements
which the dancers incorporated into
their performance on
stage for the choreography we were able
to have uh video and images so that
becomes a data set so you're then able
to start producing uh generative
outcomes which are new movements new
emotions Harry hopes it's a sign that AI
will open up new opportunities in the
Arts to those from less advantag
backgrounds and areas that I up where
you have no access to resources or
anything you can now with a click of a
button have access to Intelligence on
tap although generative AI promises
fresh opportunities and Creations debate
will continue about whether it remains
more derivative than Innovative and
whether it will deliver quantity over
quality I think the real worry about
generative AI is that it is essentially
parasitic it sucks up stuff made by
humans and remixes it and CHS it out
again and up to a point that's great but
I think at some point you do need
something genuinely new and I think the
jury's still out really on whether
generative AI is capable of producing
something truly original or whether that
still needs a human I think we should
ask who is going to consume all of these
audio segments and videos and I think
that what we need to pay attention to is
the level of content fatigue on The
Human
Side of all the concerns around ai's
impact on the entertainment business
perhaps the biggest relates to human
jobs AI is seen as a huge Threat by many
current
workers with generative AI one can
create characters at the click of a
button and in a fraction of the time
that it would have taken VFX artists to
do the same
job generative AI is already rewriting
the script for how movies are made from
special effects
waa to lip syncing for foreign films and
it's all my
fault the de aging of actors f is a fo
the disruptive power of AI is one reason
why in 2023 writers and actors swap
delivering lines for Picket lines
Hollywood actors are on strike for the
first time in 43
years the strikes that we've seen
recently in Hollywood by writers and
actors are mostly about how they get
paid but part of the strikes also is
about Ai and I think that's partly
what's helped to capture the public
imagination here the idea of computers
and Robots coming for the jobs of
writers and actors is something that
everybody can understand they got the
money we got the power these workers are
very much canaris in the coal mine
they're telling us what other Industries
are going to face we have the capacity
to scan the body voice and the facial
expression of any given an actor or Exar
and then you can use this digital Avatar
in future projects I'm going to show you
some magic AI driven accounts
impersonating the big stars are already
popular I I I don't know why I need to
speak Spanish but it's those who are
less well known both in front of and
behind the camera who may have most to
fear welcome to the last human voice
podcast exploring the moral legal and
ethical issues in artificial
intelligence in the creative sectors and
in performance syst British actor Marcus
Hutton believes AI could mean the Final
Act for much of his profession certainly
not anti any AI tools that make
workflows simpler or easier I am
uncomfortable about AI systems that are
pretty much designed to wipe out a
Workforce one group of workers under
threat are voiceover
artists skills built up over a lifetime
can be copied at the click of a button
using AI Markus fears many artists could
be facing their Curtain Call there's a
whole ecosystem a whole set of working
practices that could be just chucked in
the bin yeah it feels quite sad for me
how you look how you speak these are the
things that define you and to have it
sort of taken away and synthesized I
don't think we're ready as a as a
species for that Ready or Not the
technology is here and Marcus agreed to
have his voice cloned to test out the
ai's effectiveness so I'm going to give
speech if I AG go they've got a free
trial of Clone your own voice with one
minute of speech in a quiet environment
and by the way as the person narrating
this film I'm as interested as he is to
see the results one minute of material
is not a lot of training data but be
interesting to see what happens
speechify voice cloning allows you to
create a clone of your voice in the
future we believe everyone will clone
their voice so they never have to
re-record a voiceover when a script
changes let's see what it sounds like or
anyone else looking to elevate your
projects with top-notch voiceovers I
highly recommend giving speech by a
try it was such a small amount of data
to be trained on I can hear it's me
that's what's kind of weird it's me and
there's a bit of nuance and stuff in
there so perhaps us voiceover artists
have been granted a brief stay of
execution but AI is capable of cloning
voices and the threat to jobs is
real it's very weird the idea that you
might be competing with yourself AI is
definitely taking away jobs rapidly
station announcements checkout machines
all that kind of stuff this is the bread
and butter work for a lot of voice
artists I'm going to delete the files
now because I don't want a digital
version of me to
exist I think some people are probably
right to be looking over their shoulder
to see if the robots are coming for
their jobs the counter argument to that
is that the lower cost of producing this
content will mean that there's more
abundant stuff there's more things being
produced and all of that will ultimately
need more people to work on
it one estimate suggests that generative
AI could add between 2.6 and 4.4
trillion to the global economy annually
in the coming decades within the media
and entertainment industry this
technology is expected to increase
Revenue by 60 to $110 billion a year
as the technology improves legal
questions over copyright promise to get
thornier some argue that consent should
be obtained each time an artist work is
used by AI once your data your image has
been captured your voice has being
captured it can be repurposed multiple
times and you have no control over what
the output will be we're talking about
what we call Active consent your consent
has to be gained for each piece of work
exactly when and how consent should be
obtained is complex and not easy to
decide and it's an argument that's
already playing out in high-profile
lawsuits now some of the biggest and
bestselling authors in fiction are suing
open
AI in any dispute like this the real
winners are always the lawyers the AI
companies May well argue that what they
do constitutes a fair use of that kind
of content rather in the way that if I
read a book and it just informs my
thinking in a a general way I don't
necessarily have to pay the author of
the book if I write something on a
related subject the way in which AI
works is that it sucks up so much
information that it's very hard to
pinpoint the effect that any one data
point has on any of the output and so it
may be that they're able to argue that
they don't really owe people anything
for this it could turn out though that
it's exactly the other way around and
they find that they have to foot an
enormous bill for every piece of
information they've ever used in their
training just as it is certain that AI
will transform the entertainment
industry on many levels regulation of AI
is also so inevitable but so far it is
unclear what this will look like or how
effective it will be I'm not sure that
legislation alone would be enough to
stop this tsunami of Automation and I
think we as consumers actually have more
power than we normally realize and we do
need to tell companies if you're going
to use AI then we are not going to give
you a credit card there's no doubt that
regulation is coming to AI who comes up
with those rules and when is one of the
big questions of the years
ahead hi I'm Tom way I'm the tech and
media editor of The Economist if you'd
like to watch more about generative Ai
and entertainment business please click
on the link opposite and to watch more
of our now next series click on the
other link thanks again for watching and
please don't forget to
subscribe